good afternoon everyone
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
Tesla's 2023 annual shareholder meeting
in Austin Texas
my name is Martin Baker I'm vice
president of investor relations and I
will be the chair of today's meeting
first of all I really wanted to thank
everyone who continues to do this trip
on annual basis and shows up every time
it's really quite something that we have
a following as dedicated as this so
thank you very much for that
[Applause]
I also wanted to thank our first time
visitors I know that many of you want a
lottery to come for the first time too
in Tesla shareholder meeting
you'll probably notice that unlike many
other shareholder meetings of other
companies this one tends to be a bit
more fun so uh hope you enjoy that
but the last thing I really wanted to
say is that just thank you so much for
all your support over the years we
really feel like you're part of our
mission you know part of our uh you know
story and it's something we truly truly
value so thank you so much for that
um
there will be two parts of today's
meeting first the formal part of the
meeting where we will cover items that
stockholders have been asked to vote on
um as well as any other matters that are
properly presented and after the voting
I will introduce Tesla's co-founder and
CEO and techno King Elon Musk
who will Who will give a presentation
about this last year in review
but at this time I'd like to thank the
members of the Tesla team and the board
who are here with us here today
representative from
pricewaterhousecoopers Tesla's
independent auditor present with us as
well
but before we begin I'd like to
introduce you to Tesla's chair Robin
denholm who would like to say a few
words
[Applause]
I'm a little bit shorter so hello
everyone
on behalf of the board I am really
honored to welcome you all here today to
the 2023 annual shareholder meeting
it's wonderful for me to see everyone in
the room today and also the many
investors that have joined us today via
the virtual live stream
it's our third straight year of having
the annual meeting here in Austin
at the first meeting the factory was
still in the early stages of development
with equipment being installed and
commissioned during the 2022 meeting
production had started to ramp as we
produced about 1600 vehicles that week
and now less than a year later
we have more than tripled the amount
having achieved production of 5 000 cars
in a single week
a huge congratulation to the Texas team
and on top of that we are getting ready
to roll out our first cyber trucks
[Applause]
this exponential trajectory of the
gigafactory here in Texas is a
reflection of Tesla as a whole
in 2022 was another record-breaking year
for us with deliveries growing by 40
year year over year and that TR trend
has continued in the first quarter of
2023.
we would not be able to achieve this
growth without the dedication of our
amazing employees
I've been fortunate enough over the
years to actually travel to many of our
locations all of the gigafactories
around the world and I can tell you that
I've witnessed firsthand how our
exceptional employees in the in our
Global Talent across the world has
together achieved our mission or
furthered our mission of accelerating
the world's transition to sustainable
energy
huge round of applause please
[Applause]
here here in Texas we also had our very
first investor day where we introduced
our company leaders from design to
engineering to supply chain
manufacturing energy and charging and
they each spoke about the role of their
teams in making our mission come to life
and I was thrilled that investors were
able to hear directly from this
outstanding leadership team that Elon
has been able to put together over many
many years
it is on the strength of their
leadership and the hard work of our
dedicated employees around the world
that I believe we are not only whether
the macroeconomic environment that we've
seen this year but also continue to be
in the strongest position ever to
advance Tesla's mission
as a startup Tesla proved that electric
vehicles could be fun with the Roadster
they could even be better than
gas-powered vehicles in every single way
with the snx and could be all of these
things as well as affordable with the
model 3 and model y
which last quarter became the
best-selling vehicle of any kind in
Europe and the best-selling non-pickup
vehicle in the United States
[Applause]
and today as part as one of the world's
largest global companies we plan to
change the Paradigm again
by forging the path to achieving a
global sustainable energy economy as set
out at our investor day in our master
plan 3.
as Tesla Growers so do our customers
positive impact on carbon emissions when
I stood here last year I proudly
announced that in 2021 our customers
avoided emitting 8.4 million metric tons
of greenhouse gas emissions
the equivalent of over 20 billion miles
driven by internal combustion engine
vehicles
today I can tell you that in 2022
our customers avoided releasing over
13.4 million metric tons of greenhouse
gases into the atmosphere the equivalent
of over 33 billion miles of driving of
inter internal combustion vehicles
that's
that's an almost 6
increase in total emission savings year
over year putting more of our products
in customers hands helps grow that
number and our goals of making our
products Greener Over time and further
decarbonizing the electric grid will
help multiply that effect
as part of that goal I am delighted to
say that as described in our recent
impact report our Global supercharging
Network was again a hundred percent
renewable in 2022.
we've been able to achieve all of this
while maintaining sorry maintaining
industry margins industry leading
margins and generating strong cash flows
over the last several years
going forward we will continue our focus
on capital investment plans to support
our future growth with investments in
batteries in vehicle production
including the Next Generation platform
in the building of our lithium Refinery
that we recently broke ground on
in in the energy storage factories in
our sales and service footprint and in
our charging Network among other things
before I hand it back to Martin I would
also like to thank hero Mizuno who for
his dedicated service to the Tesla
shareholders and the board these past
three years
I would also like to express our
enthusiasm on behalf of my fellow
directors at the prospect of JB
strawball joining our board
thank you
I don't I don't have to tell you that
his passion for Tesla and Green Tech
will make him an important asset in our
mission to accelerate the world's
transition to sustainable energy so
again on behalf of the our full board
thank you for your tremendous support
and welcome to your 2023 shareholder
meeting and with that I'll hand it back
to Martin
[Applause]
thank you Robin
I will call I will now call the meeting
to order please refer to the meeting
agenda that has been provided to you and
posted on the virtual meeting site
the time is now 3 10 pm central time and
I declared the polls are now open
we have already received over the last
few weeks voting proxies from
stockholders meaning that almost all the
votes that will be counted were already
submitted before today
however if you wish to vote your shares
or change your prior vote you may do so
through the virtual meeting site for
those who are in person here today
ballots and ballot boxes were available
to you at the check-in
Tesla's board of directors has appointed
Computer Share Trust Company to serve to
serve as Inspector of Elections
Computer Share has taken and signed an
oath as Inspector and says certified
that starting on April 6 2023 the proxy
materials or a notice of internet
availability of proxy materials where
mailed were mailed or provided to all
Tesla stockholders of record March 20th
2023.
we have majority of outstanding shares
represented at the meeting so I declare
that there's a quorum present at the
meeting and we may proceed with a
meeting
the items on the agenda are as follows
number one
the election of class 1 directors Elon
Musk Robin denholm and JB Straubel to
serve for a term of three years
or until the respective successors are
duly elected and qualified
number two
to approve executive compensation on a
non-binding advisory basis
number three to approve the frequency of
future votes on executive compensation
on a non-binding advisory basis
number four to ratify the appointment of
pricewaterhousecoopers LLP
as Tesla's independent public registered
accounting firm for the 2023 fiscal year
number five
to vote on a stockholder proposal
included in our proxy statement which
relates to the reporting of key person
risk
number six to vote on a stockholder
proposal which the stockholders did not
seek to have included in our proxy
statement
this last board has recommended that our
stock stockholders vote for each of the
director nominees
for the approval by non-binding advisory
vote of executive compensation
and the ratification of employ of
appointment of PWC as an independent
registered public accounting firm for
fiscal year 2023.
and every three years for non-binding
advisory vote for the frequency of
future votes on executive compensation
with respect to stockholder proposal
included in our proxy statement which
relates to the reporting on the keyman
risk
Karen Roberts dotier on behalf of some
Tris is here to present this proposal
Miss Roberts dotier can you please
identify yourself
I would like to invite you to speak you
will have three minutes
hello uh thank you for having me here
today
under discussion is a shareholder
proposal concerning key person risk at
Tesla requiring Tessa's board to draft a
report covering the steps taken to
ameliorate the potential impacts of loss
of key persons in the company
however before I began I would first
like to say thank you to Mr Musk
for so many of us you stepped into
Fields or we had so desperately wanted
to see change and through bringing a
talented team willing to play the long
hours you dragged reluctant Industries
Kicking and Screaming into a better
future and for that thank you building
up this Juggernaut around us which as
you largely put it runs itself these
days
um thank you for that
and yet now here we are today at a time
when Tesla's technological leadership
should be on display the investment
Community largely sees us as adrift with
management focused on all the matters
not Tesla watching us Tessa's brand
favorability dropped by 15 points last
year something that costs us margins
we have such a spectacular product
pipeline at team that knows how to
execute at scale with low cost of goods
sold something that we are not being
properly recognized for should go
without saying but apparently Bears
repeating that if you cannot produce
with low cogs you have no future when I
look around the Auto industry these days
I see a lot of companies that have no
future and that's a success on behalf of
an incredible team here at Tesla that
deserves recognition
when people look at this company that's
not what they see they see the company
as a synonym for its CEO and then the
discussion turns to everything except
for where it should be focused it's my
sincere hope that by introducing this
proposal we can not only accelerate the
development of management at Tesla but
also increase its visibility the fact
that this company is so much more than
its key persons is something that the
public and the investment Community
should see
a Founder often finds their greatest
success in ensuring the future of the
company and the development of the
management Talent who can come after
them
think Tim Cook at Apple Steve Ballmer at
Microsoft and so forth people who are
ready from day one to execute without
controversy without distraction and
build a future for the company
I encourage the board should embrace
this opportunity in the most public
manner possible to showcase the future
being built right here so that the
discussion among the public and the
investment Community resolves revolves
around that and not around every public
statement on every other topic made by
the leadership
I strongly encourage the board the
shareholders to support this proposal
and for the board to embrace it thank
you very much
thank you Miss Robert store
the board is recommended that our
stockholders vote against this proposal
for the reasons set forth in our
statement of opposition in our proxy
statement
finally
as you saw and investor advocates for
social justice would like to raise a
proposal from the floor
the proponents did not seek to have
their proposal included in the proxy
statement
the board recommends that our
stockholders who are entitled to vote on
this proposal vote against it
as a reminder as is disclosed in a proxy
statement I've been advised by the proxy
holders that they intend to vote all all
shares of stock over which they have
discretionary Authority against this
proposal
only shareholders who are shareholders
of record or have obtained a legal proxy
made vote for this proposal after it is
presented
Courtney Wicks representing investor
advocates for social justice is here to
present the proposal
Miss Wix I would like you to speak you
will have three minutes thank you good
afternoon Tesla board members management
employees and shareholders my name is
Courtney Wix and I am the executive
director for investor advocates for
social justice and I'm here on behalf of
as you so and the sisters of the Good
Shepherd who have filed shareholder
proposals in the past on child labor and
human rights abuses and Tesla's supply
chain I stand here today to call on
shareholders to vote Yes on requesting
Tesla to conduct a third party report
detailing the company's efforts to
eradicate child and forced labor in its
supply chain the human rights risks that
permeate throughout Tesla's value chain
when not adequately addressed harm
shareholder value and undermine Tesla's
ability to lead the just transition
growing attention and concern have been
placed on child labor in Cobalt mining
in the Democratic Republic of the Congo
as well as on forced labor and China's
xinjiang region 70 percent of the
world's Cobalt needed for Ev batteries
are sourced in the DRC over 40 000
children work in artisanal and
small-scale Mining often without
protective equipment and in dangerous
spaces that frequently collapse many
children are seriously injured or killed
in the mining process and Tesla's latest
sustainability report it claims to have
it audited 80 percent of the miners and
refiners in their Cobalt supply chain
against responsible production standards
however there are many industry-backed
standards some of which are weak and it
isn't clear what percentage of audits
were conducted by which initiatives it
is also unclear how the company's due
diligence ensures Cobalt Source from
child labor is not intermingled in the
industrial Cobalt supply chain
subsequently an estimated 1.8 million
people have been subject to States
imposed genocide detention and
tournament camps and forced labor in the
xinjiang uyghur region a recent study
concluded that automakers cannot conduct
meaningful audits in this region the
recent uyghur forced labor prevention
act in the United States sent an inquiry
into Tesla supply chain highlights the
regulatory risk Tesla faces
we believe a third party audit would
provide greater transparency into how
Tesla plans to eradicate child enforced
labor from its supply chain
one of Tesla's competitive advantages is
its sustainable leadership
Tesla it's board of directors and
management team have a moral obligation
to pursue ethical sourcing practices
that do not rely on the lives of
children or enslaved people Tesla can
continue to make a true leadership
difference that forges a sustainable
economic future that is anchored by
Innovation empathy human development and
shareholder value thank you
thank you Miss Wicks
we will now accept votes for against or
to abstain for this proposal but again
only for record holders or legal proxy
holders
please note this is the final
opportunity to submit proxies in order
for them to be counted
I declare the polls are now closed
based on proxies we have previously
received I'd like to announce on
preliminary basis
that our stockholders have approved the
recommendations of the Tesla board on
all agenda items except that
shareholders have recommended one year
for non-binding advisory vote on the
frequency of future votes on executive
compensation
this means that I would like to
officially announce our new addition to
the Tesla board JB's travel
[Applause]
after the final tabulation is completed
we will announce specific boat tallies
filing in the filing Form 8K
within four business days of this
meeting
that concludes the official business of
today's shareholder meeting which is now
adjourned
during the course of the following
session we may discuss our business
Outlook and make forward-looking
statements such statements are
predictions based on current
expectations
actual events could result it could
differ materially due to a number of
reasons uncertainties
including those disclosed in our most
recent form 10K and thank you file links
with the secs
such forward-looking statements
represent our views as of today
should not be relied on thereafter and
we disclaim from any obligation to
update them after today
and with that please welcome Elon Musk
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
I just want to say I love you guys
[Applause]
so
uh well we've got a lot of
great news to talk about today the the
Tesla team has done an incredible job of
executing over the past year and we have
many exciting years ahead of us so uh
yeah
so with the uh it Tesla master plan part
three which admittedly was you know
quite technical we wanted to go into a
lot of technical depth
um so uh you know it was clear that they
were what we were saying what was not
just
um we're not really assertions but that
they were backed up with physics and
with real data that it's realistic
um and and with the mass plan part three
we want to basically the goal is to give
people hope realistic hope
um and maybe hopes even the wrong word
but simply to say that that there is a
path to a fully sustainable uh global
economy that we are on that path that we
are accelerating that path and that's
and that so long as we don't get
complacent about it it will happen
[Applause]
so I'll I'll just I'll kind of rush
through a recap of the mass plan part
three but the you know some of the
Salient points are that it will actually
take less energy to go to to go
sustainable not more energy uh it's it's
actually more and some of these things
may sound very obvious but it's it's
more energy efficient to go sustainable
not less
there's and and there's less mining that
is required for a sustainable any energy
economy not more also very important
um I I and I heard a question raised
about uh Cobalt mining
um
and
you know what we will do a third party
audit
so so
in fact we'll put a webcam on the mine
[Laughter]
and if anybody sees any children please
let us know
uh
I I mean I I don't want to go off on a
tangent too much on that front but if
it's very important to appreciate that
uh most of our battery packs are
iron-based
um a majority of our battery packs are
iron based not Cobalt
um and the the and then our other
battery packs are nickel based not
Cobalt the nickel batteries use a little
bit of cobalt as a binder but only a
tiny amount in contrast your phones all
use 100 Cobalt
I recommend complaining to the phone
manufacturers
[Applause]
but even for the small amount of cobalt
that we do use we will make sure six
weeks is Sunday that we're that no child
labor is being exploited obviously we're
a company that cares a lot about doing
the right thing and we don't want to
delude ourselves or delude anyone else
so yeah come
[Applause]
so
again just recapping master plan part
three uh
it's it's really the point is to say
that it is very very doable it is
happening we need a a three-fold
increase in solar and wind uh we need to
really some of these uh 29-fold increase
in vehicle stationary and thermal
battery production
um actually and I'm not sure the way to
think about sustainability is the the
the faster we can make uh battery packs
the faster we can move to a sustainable
energy economy that's the fundamental
limiting factor so let's grab some water
here
[Applause]
so
yeah this I can't emphasize that point
that point enough the the rate of uh
of of lithium-ion battery production
fundamentally decides the rate at which
the world transitions to sustainability
because the the batteries are needed for
all forms of transport and for
stationary storage given the intimate
nature of of solar and wind power
so
um
so the and we do invite people to
critique our analysis uh because you
know at any given analysis is going to
be to some degree wrong so we that's why
we put it out there looking for for
critical feedback to say uh well perhaps
we've got some things wrong perhaps some
things need to be adjusted
uh but generally the feedback we've
gotten is that actually our analysis is
quite accurate
um and uh We've not we've not seen uh
any rebuttals thus far that would cause
us to change our assumptions
so it means roughly 240 terawatt hours
of battery pack or 240 000 gigawatt
hours of battery need to be produced
but it'll only take 0.2 percent of land
area for solar and wind
so it's a very it's not like we need to
carpet the Earth with solar uh and we're
in it's just literally a fraction of a
percent
um
roughly a 10 trillion dollar
manufacturing investment which relative
to the global economy is actually a
small a small number
um yeah roughly roughly 10 percent of of
the world economy I think obviously I
think
attempts in the world economy is a small
price to pay for a sustainable energy
future
[Applause]
it's also true that even when factoring
in the cost or the the emissions
required to produce an electric vehicle
which for now are a little higher than
gasoline vehicles when you look at the
emissions over time electric vehicles
absolutely win by a long shot
um and as as we're seeing the the the
the cost uh and the emissions required
to produce an electric vehicle are
dropping rapidly over time
um and we're going to get we're going to
get to the point where an electric
vehicle is lower is cheaper than a
gasoline vehicle
so
[Applause]
so in 2022 we avoided releasing about 13
million tons of CO2
reduced uh manufacturing ghg per vehicle
by 30 and reduced water usage uh by by
15 percent uh despite massive increases
in output
so
I mean
we also made our Factory safer which is
really important so we tracked the the
injuries per person and we believe at
this point we are best in industry or
have the lowest injuries per person so
[Applause]
we're now actually quite a big company
from a headcount standpoint this is this
is our direct uh employment number so
this does not count contractors
and for every manufacturing job
depending on on how you count it there
are at least five uh sometimes up to 10
jobs created uh because you've got to
look at the total supply chain as well
as the all of the support functions so
you know when you create a factory like
this you actually create jobs for
teachers lawyers Carpenters electricians
and and restaurants and and everything
that's that's required to support a
person at a factory and this is why
countries and and states are so
interested in having uh
manufacturing facilities in their
location so anyways it's it's a lot of
people gainfully employed doing doing
very useful things
uh we received a 3.6 million job
applications uh last year so
uh
[Applause]
and um
and and once again the uh the top two
most desired companies for engineers
um
on Earth uh were SpaceX and Tesla
so
[Applause]
you know at the end of the day the
competitiveness of Any Given company is
a function of what where are the most
talented people interested in working
that that is the team that's going to
win
in fact if I'd say this is General
generally the case if you look at any
given company and say where are the most
smartest most driven people going to
work
that company is going to win
so whether it's Tesla or any other
company
we're also excited to announce our
next-gen Drive Unit
um which is a big reduction in silicon
carbide it's half the factory space uh
notably there are zero Rare Earth
elements required
so
yeah
and we're also
changing to a 40 volt 48 volt low
voltage architecture in the in the car
so
uh yeah this is a big deal actually
um
[Applause]
so the the uh cars have been operating
with 12 volt batteries for basically
about a century
so for the first time in
I think over a hundred years uh we're
actually going to change from 12 volt uh
voltage of you know outside of the
drivetrain to a 48 volt uh architecture
and to First approximation that that
means we need only about a quarter as
much copper
for uh in the in the car as would be
needed for a 12 volt battery
so that's a big deal because people
often worried about you know is there
enough copper yes there is
so
[Applause]
um and FSD beta is growing uh hyper
exponentially
so that that chart is going to look like
a wall basically
um
and um I just question for for those in
the room are you have how many people
have tried out FSD beta okay great
so so what what do you think of the
latest build
right
so it's um
it's really getting to the point where
it's uh at least for me when I drive
around it's uh several days between
interventions
um and I think we're we're getting to
the point where
um there's really just one last piece of
of the system that needs to be a neural
net which is the
the planning and Control Function
um and and so we expect to have that
last piece become neural net so it'll be
end to end from a video into control out
as a neural net
um
and yeah so the thing the thing to
appreciate is it's not that uh full
self-driving will be as good as a person
it will be much much better
like a lot like over time and uh 10
times more 10 times safer than a person
it's not even going to be a contest
frankly
um so this is this is a really big deal
um and I think some people realize that
I think you guys probably realize it but
uh
being able to do a software update and
have several million cars suddenly go
from manual driving to
autonomous I think will be the single
biggest asset value increase in history
um so
[Applause]
the normal usage of a passenger car is
roughly 10 to 12 hours per week call it
maybe an hour and a half per day
and when you drive around you see lots
of cars just parked in parking lots
because out of the 168 hours in a week
they're using less than less than 10
percent maybe seven percent of the hours
of the week a car is in use but once it
is autonomous it can be used probably I
don't know 50 50 hours a week maybe more
so
it's it if it is effectively a five-fold
increase in the value of a car overnight
um
I'm actually surprised that so few
people uh realize this or maybe they
just don't believe it it's real
um but but it is so
this is this is really
an insanely big deal
uh we're also the the largest ev maker
in the world
um so
[Applause]
yeah
and I think that will continue
um and while at the same time being the
highest margin of any car maker in the
world
[Applause]
and I'm making electric vehicles
profitably is is hard as illustrated by
the difficulty of our competitors a
number a number of our competitors are
making EVS at a significant loss
so
but we are not we are actually making
EVs profitably and almost no one else is
this is hard so
um
and I'd say for this is It's a massive
credit to the Tesla team for I I can't
tell you how hard manufacturing is like
you've probably heard me say that
prototypes are easy manufacturing is
hard
um and and then and then manufacturing
at scale uh with positive cash flow is
excruciating
it's Mega pain
um but the Tesla team has done it
so
and as you can see our free cash flow
per year has been increasing steadily
so you know we're making good progress
um I mean it it should be said that uh
and I've made some of these comments
um
that the the that interest rates make up
a very big have a very big effect on the
affordability of cars
so
the vast majority of people buy cars
based on the monthly payment so it's
like how much money how much is monthly
payment
um and it's it's not a it's not a
question of of value for money it's just
do they actually have enough money can
they afford it
um so people so for the vast majority of
people is just can they afford to pay
the payment as the interest rates
increase
um and credit tightens
um like it's safe to say that the you
know these various banks that
um have died are probably
uh somewhat distracted
um from handing out Auto loads you know
it's like if they're on the way to the
cemetery
increasing the auto loan portfolio is
not the first thing on their mind
um so this is going to be a challenging
I'd say a challenging 12 months I want
to be sort of realistic about it that
Tesla is not immune to the global
economic environment
um I I expect
things to be just at a macroeconomic
level
um difficult for at least the next 12
months
um
like Tesla will get through it and we'll
do well and I think we'll see a lot of
companies actually go bankrupt so I I
want to make sure that this is not just
the good news parade
it's important to to understand that no
company is immune to the macroeconomic
environment
but that said the it won't be Darkness
uh forever I expect probably a year of
difficulty
uh globally for everyone
um and then my my best guess is that the
global economy turns around uh in
roughly 12 months
um and and then Tesla will be in an
extremely good position
so anyone who is a long-term investor I
think will do extremely well
[Applause]
and um here I want to give a big shout
out to the Tesla internal software uh
Team this is um
it's actually a really big deal that uh
Tesla has such a powerful internal
software team
um I mean that that software team is
responsible for handling the entire uh
customer experience from from buying the
car delivering the car uh operating the
factories
service and support we internally wrote
all of the Insurance and financial
software
um
the it's or the supply chain and
Logistics stuff the data centers the
infrastructure
um and the analytics Insight this is all
uh internally written Tesla software and
I think there's there are almost no
companies in the world can do this uh
because they do not have uh a a very
talented internal uh software team so
they're generally reliant on third-party
um enterprise resource planning software
so but Tesla is not this this is this is
a hidden strength of the company
um that often doesn't get a lot of
attention but is incredibly powerful so
once again I'd like to thank them for
their work
and uh as predicted
um we are highly confident that model y
will be the number one best-selling car
on Earth this year
[Applause]
and in fact in Europe the best-selling
car of any kind yeah whatsoever it
already was that in q1 I should say
um it's not like will be it was that in
q1 uh and uh China's best-selling SUV
and the United States the best-selling
uh non-pecup vehicle in the United
States in q1 so
um you know it's going well
[Applause]
uh I don't know if this is like the
optimal picture but
um the the uh
it's uh Tesla cars are actually the the
safest cars in the world we put
um immense effort into vehicle safety
and we keep updating the safety so we
keep improving the automatic emergency
braking system just with a software
update and we keep improving the airbag
deployment with software updates so we
close the feedback loop on like when we
see an accident we analyze the accident
we say what can we do from a software
standpoint because there's actually
quite a lot you can do to first of all
avoid the accident because the best
accident is no accident and then if the
accident occurs how do we deploy the
airbags uh and the the sort of the seat
belt pre-tensioners to minimize the
probability of injury
um and uh
so even even for cars that people have
owned for many years uh we are behind
the scenes uh continuously uh improving
the safety of of your car and um and
there are even some things that I think
a lot of people aren't aware of that we
we actually have automatic Cavern cabin
overheat protection
so uh never in the history of the
company has a a child or a pet died in a
Tesla
all right
so it's it's one of those like little
known features but uh because we have a
large battery and we're monitoring
things all the time we can make sure
that the cabin temperature uh never gets
to lethal levels
um and uh I think that's that's uh yeah
big deal so
um oh yeah so and then
um while lots of cars will say they've
got like you know five stars or or
whatever
um
uh there's there's Nuance to that
um when we do did the European end cap
uh sort of active safety tests uh we got
the highest scores that they've ever
seen
so yeah
[Applause]
so we we we got a 98 uh score on the
active safety system
um which obviously isn't good enough
um and we will
but we we have got a game plan for uh
getting rid of the last two percent
[Applause]
and then it's worth noting things like
the total cost of ownership of a model 3
is now comparable to that of a Toyota
Toyota Corolla
so
um superchargers we're making uh good
progress so our supercharger uptime is
now 99.95 percent
so yeah
[Applause]
and we have superchargers practically
everywhere at this point
uh going to mega pack
um because this is a stationary storage
is an important part of solving the
sustainable energy problem
um and the the Tesla mega pack is now
more competitive than a natural gas
speaker plant so we have very strong
demand for the Tesla mega pack
um and uh we're going to make a lot of
them so
[Applause]
um and a while back I predicted that the
Tesla
stationary battery packed business would
actually grow faster than the automotive
side of things and that's exactly what
has happened uh you can see it's it's an
it's an exponential curve uh growing at
a rate that that is even faster than our
vehicle sales
so
yeah sorry
um
we're expanding gigafactory Nevada
for the Tesla semi-production line and
for the 4680 in in-house cell production
and uh yeah some Mega Factory
stuff
so
this is um so
we're aiming for 40 gigawatt hours a
year both in California and in China but
I think
um long term this will be uh much much
greater than this I mean I would say I
wouldn't be surprised if long term uh
the stationary battery pack uh
activity went uh well in excess of 500
gigawatt hours per year
so the the demand is like quite quite as
the infinite here
so
[Applause]
um as we look ahead to tackle the what
we see as the choke points in the supply
chain one of them is lithium refining
um and uh I mean there's been a few
times on Tesla earnings calls where I've
said Can someone please just do lithium
refining
um because uh
it's it's there's a shortage of it
um and uh but we we really see very
little activity outside of China for for
lithium refining so
um
it's not that we wish to take on extra
problems but since nobody else was doing
it we felt we had to do this and so uh
we've just Broken Ground on lithium
Refinery and Corpus Christi which will
be
um do more lithium refining then I think
probably everything outside of China
so yeah
[Applause]
Andrew signed a deal for our next
gigafactory and in Mexico Giga Mexico uh
and I I think that's going to be a
fantastic Factory
so uh yeah we're we're laying the
groundwork for
um ultimately getting to 20 million
Vehicles a year
[Applause]
so cyber truck is a hard car to make
um
it's because it's a such a radically new
design it actually you can't just use
conventional methods of manufacturing we
had to invent
a whole new set of manufacturing
techniques in order to build an
exoskeleton based car instead of an
endoskeleton based car so it's it's
extremely non-trivial to to build the
Cyber truck
but we're making good progress on that
we have the
um
so so yes so I that that's the the thing
I when I
um in the factory I I tour the Cyber
Truck Line to see how we're doing there
and um
and uh
sorry for the delay but we're finally
going to start delivering production
cyber trucks later this year and I think
the product if anything is better than
expectations
all right
I mean cyber truck is the is the car I
will be driving on a day-to-day basis
um
so and you know people always want to
know what our next product is
um
but this is not the time to
we obviously need to have a you know a
proper dedicated product launch
um I I just want to emphasize that we
are actually building a new product we
are actually designing a new product uh
we're not sitting in our hands here
um so uh there are
two new products that I think you will
be very excited about
[Applause]
and both the design of the products and
the manufacturing techniques are
Head and Shoulders above anything else
that is present in industry
so yeah anyways
[Applause]
if I were to guess I I would say of
these these two new products just these
two new products alone I I would say
this
what we will probably make obviously
this is just you know elon's guess
um so you know don't sue me
um
but uh I I you know elon's guess is that
that will probably make in excess of
five million units a year of these two
models combined so
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
by the way
[Music]
perfect
[Applause]
but I think the thing
um most notable is if you look at the
difference between the last time we
showed Optimus and and this was a video
that was taken basically yesterday
um and The Optimist team was up all
night uh making this video
um the Optimus team has done an
incredible job
um so just yeah
and it's uh
the the the
motors the controllers the electronics
and everything you see in the Optimus
robot is a tesla-designed uh
system so this is we actually tried to
find
um
Drive actuators and and whatnot that
that were off the shelf we we found that
there weren't any
um in order to make
um
and and an effective uh humanoid robot
you actually have to design the motors
and gearboxes and the electronics from
scratch because it's a very different
application from anything else that
exists
um so we took our world-class motor and
Power Electronics team and uh and said
okay we need to design several um uh
actuators that are that don't exist in
the world
um and they did so
Optimus is is working quite well and
then
for full self-driving as for
self-driving gets closer and closer to
generalized real world AI
that same software is transferable to a
humanoid robot
just like
um you know uh we you know humans can
obviously walk around with their arms
and legs but but we can drive a car fly
a plane
uh steer a boat uh ride a horse
um
if you have a generalized understanding
or if you have generalized real world AI
which is what we are developing for full
self-driving it can be transferred to
basically anything
um
and um
so so optimists will use the same FSE
computer as as the car
and um
The Optimist stuff is is
um I think somewhat not somewhat
extremely underrated
because that people just cannot
comprehend the the the consequences now
obviously we need to make sure that we
don't have a Terminator scenario that's
very important uh it's all fun and games
until Terminator shows up
um
but uh if you say like if you have had a
generalized
um humanoid robot
uh what would be the effective ratio of
humanoid robots to humans
because I think basically everyone would
want one and and maybe people would want
more than one
which means the
actual demand for for something like
Optimus if it really works
um which will
is
uh
I don't know I mean 10 billion units
it's it's some crazy number
um
it might be 20 billion units If the
ratio is say two to one on people you
know humanoid robots versus people it
might actually be
it's not it's some very big number is
what I'm saying
um and a number of vastly in excess of
the number of cars
um so my prediction is that Tesla's
long-term value
will be a majority of long-term value
will be optimists
and that prediction I'm very confident
of
so anyway
[Applause]
let's see so I think with that we can do
questions perhaps
oh okay what is it oh yeah we also want
to make sure uh retail investors please
please vote normally retail investors uh
for most companies don't vote but you we
really care about your vote
um of of small investors not just a lot
of large investors so please do register
to vote your vote is very important
um
and uh yeah I think that's
yeah that's that's it so
um
so with that we can go to
ad hoc questions from the audience
okay definitely the person in the
Optimus outfit with the red cowboy hat
[Laughter]
[Applause]
great outfit
um
sure uh
you know we'll try to get to as many
questions as possible and uh you know
you hit me with your
toughest questions fine
okay it is Hey Dad it's your son Optimus
do you do you see it more likely that
you guys will have an RV first or a
cyber camper
we don't have any plans to build an RV
uh quite yet although I I can certainly
see how cyber truck could be converted
into an RV
um and we are um
adding a lot of sort of attach points to
cyber truck so others can build things
you know you know somebody could have a
startup or other companies can build
things that are attachments that enhance
cyber truck and turn it into a camper
essentially
um because I think it'd be really cool
to have all these like third-party
things available for cyber truck
I mean you could also probably just
you're that close you can just say it or
something I don't know
actually we'd like you guys to queue up
behind us okay three months all right
yes
and uh
try to make the question short so we can
get to a lot of questions
um
so uh
Maybe
Oh Oh you mean just like a just like a
Tesla team doing a podcast about Optimus
oh yeah yeah sure
um
yeah you know I wonder if um maybe we
could add have a sort of like a an
addendum after the earnings call which
is like a
you know 30 minutes watch podcast on
Optimus or something like for those who
are interested okay I think we'll do
that
so
[Music]
all right
hey lone thanks for doing this today
it's an awesome event thank you welcome
thanks for coming hope you guys having a
good time yeah having a great time
[Applause]
I I'm pretty confident we have the
funnest uh shareholders meeting by a
long shot undoubtedly yeah it's amazing
so I'm really excited about a lot of
things with Tesla it's hard to pick a
good question that it's going to cover
everything but with the energy side of
the business I think it's hugely
underrated I mean we've got tons of
problems I mean California with rolling
blackouts how do you think you can
incentivize people you know more for
solar battery backup and we've got the
referral programs been beefed up as well
so you know what are your thoughts there
how we can get people on board yeah um
actually one of the challenges um in
California and a few other places is
that in order to have uh the power wool
um be be like an uninterruptible power
supply for the house we have to actually
have a switch that uh
disconnects you from the utility
otherwise you just you know
send energy into the grid and it doesn't
do anything
and that's actually been quite difficult
with the utilities but I'd like to thank
PG e for for recently uh helping us uh
get approval for installing the backup
switch for powerwall in California uh so
that people can have uninterrupted power
in California and we're working on that
uh in in every jurisdiction so
um
so I'm confident that that's that's a
that's going to be a great long-term
situation and then as I mentioned mega
pack uh is is growing uh very very
rapidly
um
and uh yeah so things are I mean things
are really growing like ridiculously
fast on the the energy storage front so
yeah I feel I feel good about that
situation all right next question uh
Elon
um a lot of people have just kind of
been wondering how are you doing so I
was wondering what's up how you doing
how you feeling we saw you were partying
in Cabo recently so just what must have
been someone else so how are you doing
just human to human how you doing
well I have to say it's a bit of a you
know roller coaster situation
um
and um
you know like
it's it's actually pretty rare for me to
be at a party
um so that's like the
you know first party I've been at in a
while
um
and actually it wasn't even going to go
to it then my brother talked me into it
so thanks Kimball
um
so um
yeah I have to say like the sometimes
the the the the work pain level is quite
excruciating
um and then and then on top of that I
get dumped on in the Press so it's like
you know it's not exactly super fun
um but um
you know and there was a you know a
short-term distraction because uh I had
to do like some major open heart surgery
uh on on Twitter to ensure the company
survival
um but that I think Twitter is now in a
stable place and obviously very excited
to have uh Linda yacorino join and um
so I I think Linda's gonna do a great
job running running Twitter
um and uh I'll provide obviously
guidance on uh and uh you know
technology development but as you can
see I think Twitter at this point has
released more new features in the last
six months than it has in the last six
years
so
you know obviously this is not a Twitter
meeting but but but but the the larger
point is that I feel at this point I
don't need to devote incremental time uh
the amount of time that Twitter will
take going forward is is a relatively
small compared to the last six months
um so yeah
um
you know you know apart from like
there's like some macroeconomic things
that we can't do anything about
um overall I feel uh very good about the
health of the companies and um I'm
increasingly optimistic about the future
thanks for asking it's kind of your ask
have you guys considered stretching out
the financing terms on your auto
business you talked about earlier uh
consumers don't necessarily look at the
sticker price they're paying they're all
they're concerned about is monthly
payment right and one of the fundamental
advantages of an EV is that is
substantially more durable and so
um would you guys ever consider
stretching terms out to 10 years
especially in this rate environment get
in the shape of the yield curve you know
extending the terms out that farther
you'd actually be capturing a lower cost
of funds
yeah I mean the important thing to
appreciate is that like
um
that that the vast majority of the the
financing is from Banks so it's kind of
whatever the banks are prepared to do
um I mean this year I guess we'll do on
the order of 100 billion dollars of
sales
um and we don't have 100 billion dollars
in cash to finance that so the vast
majority of it has got to come from uh
you know from Banks
um
so it's really the bank's choice of what
they're willing to do
um and it's it has been tricky with uh
with with banks recently because as I
mentioned earlier it's
if you're a bank and you're not sure
whether you're going to be alive or not
uh you're that's it's a pretty big
distraction and increasing your auto
loan portfolio is uh very much a
secondary priority so it's just
important to appreciate it's not up to
Tesla it's up to the banks
um and there's not there's not some easy
solution where you can say have a circle
a captive financing arm Etc because you
have to securitize those loads and the
market for securitizing them is is weak
there is no
I wish there was an easy path but but
there isn't
um
so
you know I think just important remember
that the economy moves in cycles and
we've had a very long period of upcycle
in the next 12 months will be I think
difficult for everyone and I think
you know when Berkshire Hathaway had
their annual meeting uh Warren and
Charlie actually said like hey this this
year the Berkshire companies are going
to make less money
um and so and you know they're they're
they're very well run organizations and
I think that's just generally true for
the economy so
you know but but if but but but
it's also important to remember that you
know there are good times and and there
are dark times but then the good times
follow the dark types so
um
my advice would be
don't look at the markets for the next
12 months
yeah
if if there's a dip buy the dip
[Laughter]
um and I think you will not be sorry
because the the you know there's just
generally a sort of a
there's an economic cycle to things but
things come back up so
um
my guess is tough times for a year like
like I said just just my guess uh and
and but then Tesla will emerge stronger
than ever
um and the the long term if you say like
net present value of future cash flows
will be incredible in my opinion
all right
[Applause]
hey Elon meet Kevin here hey how's it
going good thanks so uh Tesla is the
largest position in my ETF ticker PP and
that's for pricing power right and uh
I'm curious I really think that some of
the features that you highlighted here
like the uh over-the-air airbag
deployments of improving features the
safety features are great things that we
could be advertising for I know you've
heard this many months before I know you
have but no no sorry go ahead go ahead
yeah 525 bucks off every car this year
is half a Netflix's advertising budget
thousand bucks is the entire Netflix
advertising budget and I see their ads
everywhere why not advertise these
things that you told us here I feel like
nobody else knows about this I just
talked to Gordo the Tesla bear and he's
still talking about 2016 New York Times
pieces these people are in the past man
that's like seven years ago at this
point I mean that's what I'm saying yeah
it's actually I talked to a lot of
people and they still think that like
Teslas are like super expensive and like
no actually the starting price for a
Tesla is below the average auto price in
the US
it's like
and that's a good thing
I mean I think it's it's it's good that
it's that way you know like which our
goal was always to make cars that are
affordable to the general public
um so
so I I hear you I mean I think
um and it's indeed ironic that you know
Twitter is like highly dependent on
Advertising so
um you know here I am it's like uh you
know not never use advertising really
before and uh now uh
have a company that's highly dependent
on Advertising so
um I I guess I should say advertising is
awesome and everyone should do it
but but I I think I I hear your your uh
sort of logical point which is that
um there are amazing features and
functionality about Tesla is that people
just don't know about
um and um
so yeah
and and and although there's this
obviously a lot of people that uh
followed like say the Tesla account and
and the uh uh you know my account
whatever on Twitter
um uh to some degree it is preaching to
the choir and the choir is already
convinced
um so I think what you're saying um does
does have some Merit and um
you know what I I believe in taking
taking suggestions so um we'll we'll try
a little advertising and see how it goes
okay okay
all right I was I wasn't I wasn't
expecting that level of enthusiasm but
uh okay it sounds like our shareholders
if I read between the lines
subtle as it is are saying we should
probably do some advertising okay very
well all right
[Applause]
Highland Heights thank you for
everything so my question is regarding
you recently add steam to the car and
that's great we can play video games
it's just like currently developing the
ability for other parties to develop
apps for the car for example if if we
come by actually customizable teams for
the operator ships of the car I think
you you can make some Revenue there like
that's that space to use for the car or
lower the Rings or stuff like that do
you have any interest on that right now
well um
I mean the important so I think the
the notion of having entertainment apps
and whatnot becomes increasingly
important as the cars achieve
self-driving because otherwise the the
you you can only really watch uh play
games or watch movies or whatever when
the car is stationary you know which you
know if it's charging or what whatever
that then you can use it but when it's
when it's at the point in which it's
full stop driving I think it's very much
about entertainment uh and productivity
um so I think that is something that
might make sense in the future
um
the but overwhelmingly the Focus right
now uh from for Tesla software apart
from improving safety is achieving full
self-driving and then getting full
self-driving to be much safer than human
driving
um
and then once as we once we achieve full
self-driving I think that there could be
a lot of opportunity for for apps and
whatnot
um
so if it you know even the car as it is
today for a Model S and X
um we've we've made a sort of a full
um uh steam integration so you can
actually just literally log on with it
with a model SRX with your Steam account
and play any game that is on Steam which
is a lot of games
uh which is pretty wild I think a lot of
people don't know that you can play with
a keyboard and mouse you can play with a
joystick or controller you can also play
Netflix YouTube or anything else
um iron for my little son x uh he loves
watching uh you know actually loves
watching Rocket videos uh in the for on
the in the rear screen of the the model
S and X so
um
yeah so it is something that we will do
long term
but one of the things we already have a
lot of stuff there and we'll do more as
uh self-driving becomes a reality so
so
hey Elon I'm John or Dr know it all on
YouTube and I don't know it all but
anyway my question is as you guys move
completely or finish the transition and
full self-driving from version 1.0 of
the software to 2.0 what do you perceive
of as the like potential stumbling
blocks after that because it seems like
that's the major you know kind of Step
change that needed to happen and so
you're almost done with that and what
happens after that and also please let
me interview about you about full
self-driving like I'll I'll spend two
hours just that
well
there's there's what I can really think
about full self-driving as
um
uh sort of a March of nines of
reliability so we we need to get to the
point where the probability of injury is
uh lower than that of the average human
driver and then ultimately probability
of injury is much lower so even at the
point at which the card is capable of
driving itself there's still actually a
lot of work to do
um because you know every year there's a
million people that die in auto
accidents and I think uh
probably everyone in this audience has
friends and family that that have died
or been seriously injured in auto
accidents
um and and for every there's like a
million people that died there's there's
10 million people roughly that are
seriously like permanently injured
um
and um and and and so it matters that we
you know if if we can get that
um down by an order of magnitude you
know there's like 900 000 lives saved
per year maybe nine million severe
injuries prevented per year
um and so that that really I think
morally has to be our primary goal
um
and um
I I guess I'm open to uh
an interview on on FSD
um
two hours a long time but
okay okay
um
all right I'll I'll do an interview it's
going to be on Twitter but sure
[Laughter]
all right
hi hi Elon I'm Josh Phillips long-term
retail investor my questions about uh
battery grade lithium supply in the next
10 years
um you know lithium experts all agree
that mines are just not coming on online
fast enough uh to meet battery supply
and actually Drew Bagley no point this
out recently some mines have take 10
years plus to be permitted and even GM
has actually announced like huge lithium
deals that will like secure away Supply
from the rest of the industry so what's
Tesla's plans to get more supply of
lithium uh at the Mine level outside of
refining but also at a deeper level than
a traditional off take because as we
know he who controls the spice controls
the universe
sure um
so
um
I I actually think that the the industry
analysis is is incorrect
um
and the the constraint is fundamentally
that of processing
um
so
now our refinery in Corpus Christi that
we're building is um you know primarily
oriented towards refining exposure mean
of which there is a truly vast amount in
the world
um about I think about three quarters of
our lithium comes from Australia
um and frankly you could increase the
rate at which the mines are operating
um and the limiting factor is uh is is
not how fast can you mine but how fast
can you can you process
so the the the minds are only gonna
produce ore at the rate at which
refineries can handle the ore or they'll
it's pointless so
um I think my opinion and obviously I
could could be wrong about this but is
is that it's it's really not not about
the lithium or lithium is extremely
common lithium is everywhere in every
every country's got lithium it's not
like oil
so lithium is one of the most common
elements on Earth
um but taking the lithium ore and
refining it to battery grade is
extremely difficult because the Purity
levels required for a battery are
extremely high if you have even a small
impurity then you will degrade the life
of the cell dramatically so you need
Ultra Pure battery grade lithium and
that's why that's why our focus is on
refining as opposed to mining thank you
[Applause]
hi Elon uh thanks it's a great time here
uh you spoke about safety in your
presentation of these vehicles and I
just want to say uh I'm thankful to you
for building such a safe vehicle because
I'm here today with my son uh we drove
in his Tesla 3 over here uh that he
replaced with the one that he got
rear-ended significantly and it
destroyed the car but we're able to be
here today so great thank you very much
absolutely
so what's your way to look okay hey uh
how's it going my name is Austin Gregory
um I'll ask about this because I don't
think it gets near enough love but I was
wondering if there are any updates on
the next gen Roadster actually yeah I
know I know it's sort of like the cherry
on top and uh all that stuff you guys
have a lot of a lot on your plate if
you've said before but if there's any
updates on like the release timeline all
that stuff the SpaceX package maybe yeah
yeah um that'd be amazing thanks uh
totally uh fair and reasonable question
um where is that thing
um
um so uh we expect to complete uh the
engineering and design of the next-gen
Tesla roads to this year and hopefully
hopefully stock production is not a
commitment but hopefully start
production next year
so
um
but
I I it it is like it is like as you
alluded to it's it's it's not even the
icing on the cake it's the cherry on the
icing on the cake
um so I would I wouldn't expect it to be
like uh it's definitely not going to be
a huge contributor to to revenue it will
be a modest contributor to profitability
but it will be sick
[Laughter]
so
and um
you know there's some value to me
running two companies because uh the the
next gen Roadster will have the SpaceX
option package
so
Ben that'll make it truly next level
hey Ilan Evan McMillan here
first of all I want to thank you for
making the absolute best safest and most
fun
cars in the whole world
cars in in Florida you could we are
seeing many many more cars in Florida
than a year ago yeah matter of fact cars
are doubled so um the question is we all
want
Tesla insurance is it coming
oh yeah yeah um actually that's a great
question uh
uh okay Zach Zach says it's coming later
this year but I have to tell you like
the one of the thorniest things uh in
the United States is car insurance uh or
Insurance in general because it's a
state by state and every State's got
different rules and regulations
um so that's why it's not like rolled
out uh Nationwide I think really there
should be
One National Standard for insurance
especially car insurance I think it
would improve the cost effective cost
effectiveness of car insurance but our
but our intent is to to roll out
Nationwide and ultimately
internationally
um
but there is a staggering amount of
paperwork that is that is needed uh to
uh to to get it done but as Zach said we
expect to offer Tesla Insurance in uh in
Florida later this year thank you
thank you
thank you Elon Alexandra Mertz I'm Tesla
Mama very happy to be here
so very grateful to the Tesla team and
you of course just want you to know we
love the emotions every day joy and less
Joy but we're there shareholders it's
not easy we're here not because it's
easy but because it's hard so my
question initially was on in-house
financing you already answered that and
I want to congratulate you to the double
investment grade rating but then I asked
my Twitter subscribers I'm sure you're
going to appreciate what they wanted to
bring forward and that question made the
cut here we go
Automotive including SAS Peak margin the
same for energy
what number and by when do you have the
best Elon guest that we get there
so I'm not sure I fully understand the
question so this is the peak margin for
automobile mod for automobile including
SAS
and energy and by when will we get there
you'll guess I know nobody will sue you
sorry what's SAS well server software as
a service oh okay
um
you mean FS self-driving
FSD what's going to be the top
automobile
Market oh oh yeah yeah I mean that what
I was saying earlier is is that
um at the point at which you have uh a
truly autonomous vehicle that can drive
around with with no one in it
um the utility of the vehicle I I think
as a rough guess is probably five times
what uh it is today because you know
people will drive an average of an hour
and a half a day perhaps uh so 10 hours
a week but if the car is autonomous it
can probably I'm just just speculation
but it probably can operate for
a third of the hours in the week which
would mean 50 or more hours thus a
five-fold increase but but the car costs
the same
but what is going to be the margin for
Tesla then because you're obviously
thinking you're gonna sell much more FSD
then right you may have a system in
place of Robo taxes you may have a cut
with fleets so did you do any
projections what the automotive Peak
margin for Tesla could be in two years
five years and the same for energy
well I mean this is definitely we're in
sort of Highly speculative territory
here
um but but obviously if if you've got a
car that costs the same and and has say
I don't know a 20 or 25 margin and
suddenly is able to be used five times
as much then then you might have 80
margins
and the revenue would increase
several Folds
that's why I say it's the is probably
going to be the biggest asset value step
change in in history of Earth
yeah
and and energy does not have the energy
just simply does not have
such an increase in asset utilization so
I would expect energy to be to remain at
sort of a 20 20 25 percent ish to 30
margin
all right so you said ask the tough
questions you're still good right yeah
all right cool first of all though as a
family man I just want to say there's a
couple of things like a loop for tether
of us of a car seat going through the
headrest which would be super helpful
there's a couple other things that would
be really nice model Y is the only one
you can do that in today maybe we could
fix that but
when we're thinking about 4680 battery
cells should we be thinking about the
efficiency and the performance we're
getting today or is there some updated
timeline path that we could see closer
to battery day presented efficiency
performance that we can look to in the
future
um well I think first of all it's really
important to express like Express the
difficulty of
you know like
for Tesla to go from from nothing to
making a battery cell that we aspire to
be better than any other battery cell on
Earth even when compared to companies
where the only thing they do is make a
battery cell uh is is obviously not a
trivial exercise
um that that said uh we do see a path to
to you know High very high energy
density and higher energy density and
lower costs than than anything else out
there
but it's a hard path it's a very hard
path
um
and and normally this it would be absurd
for companies to attempt such a thing
and no other car company is is really
attempting to do anything like this uh
in a serious way
so I guess technically byd because they
started out as a battery company but
um
yeah so it's it's a it's a very
difficult thing to do
um but I think we are tracking to
success in that regard so
hey Elon first of all thank you for
undoubtedly making the world a better
place for my son to live in thank you
can't even say
uh once cyber truck is fully ramped in
Austin what is the target production and
also there's some rumors that you're
thinking about stepping down as CEO
please say it ain't so it ain't so
uh
[Applause]
yeah so
I think Tesla's going to play an
important role uh in in AI
um and AGI and uh I I think I need to
oversee that to make sure it's it's good
so
um because that's that's a thorny
problem if there ever was one
um
you know like I I think generally people
do not
um or very few people even in the AI
Community do not
um
uh appreciate uh just how much
capability Tesla has in AI
um
it's by far the most advanced real world
AI there's no one even close
um
and reality has the most degrees of
freedom
so
I got to make sure that's good
um
so and you're saying something
cyber truck fully ramps oh yeah
um
so
I said you know we'll start production
later this year we'll start handing over
costly this year there will be an
s-curve of production so it'll be slow
at first and then and then ramping up
and I guess we'll see what the demand is
like uh so
I mean I think there's
we're likely to do probably
um a quarter million a year I think
maybe more
um again very much dependent on on what
the demand is like and
um and it's it's
you know we don't just need to ramp up
production but we also needed to
um improve the the production cost
efficiency
so which is going to be also a very very
hard thing
so
but I'd say it's you know a quarter
million a year is is a reasonable guess
um and it might be 500 000 I don't know
but we'll make as many as people want
and can afford
um and and and and but and then like I
said it's going to be hard to make the
cost of affordable because it is a new
car A new manufacturing method so
um
in in the grand scheme of things
relative to the production rate of all
the other cars we make it will be small
um
but it's still very cool
um yeah thanks you know maybe three more
questions sure
oh thank you
good day Mr musk hello my name is Delia
Archer and this question aims to address
Tesla's efforts in developing skilled
Workforce attracting diverse talent and
promoting career opportunities within
the company when I look around I see a
lot of young faces and I think about
internships and apprenticeships for
students in high school and beyond my
question is are there any plans to
expand existing Partnerships and explore
new avenues for collaborations with
educational institutions and non-profit
organizations to attract the Next
Generation in very career pathways
um yeah actually we with with all of our
gigafactories we work with the the local
schools actually from the high school
level community college and university
because it's incredibly important to
Foster the talent for the factories as
you saw from the the employment numbers
we actually need a lot of people even
though we've got a lot of automation we
still need a lot of people to operate
the factories and really matters that
they have the the right training so
we're big Believers in in reaching out
to educational institutions uh and um
because frankly it's in our interest to
do so
um so uh thank you for asking the
question
all right
Elon Josh Fuller I had originally
thought of asking about the the fund
police and pushing back on the Boombox
and allowing us to Screech at people
with goats again but uh after seeing
Optimus I was inspired to ask does has
anybody asked optimus's opinion of Mars
and does he have a ticket yet
uh well you know Optimus is not a deep
thinker at this point
um
so Optimus is a
still you know
figuring out how to do basic stuff
um
like it like it it couldn't make uh you
know cook some eggs or something quite
yet
um if so we need to get optimists to the
point where uh it has
um
reasonable agility and can and can do
basic things
um and um you know and we're aiming for
it to start off doing Simple tasks that
are sort of boring and repetitive
um or some or dangerous uh basically
jobs people don't want to do
so that that's that's our goal uh and
and um I'm confident we'll we'll achieve
that goal
um and then uh we've got to figure out
how to make it at scale make sure that
the robots the robot is safe
um I think it's going to be very
important to have a local means of
turning it off
um
so
safety is gonna safety is going to be
extremely important um
I can't emphasize that enough
um but but right now it
it is not at an intelligence level where
it's pondering uh questions like Mars
perhaps it will be one day so
hi good afternoon
my name is Luke Arsenault I just want to
start off by saying big thank you to you
and the team of Tesla for all you guys
do it's been great to see and I'm so
happy for you guys
my question is with the rise in cyber
security threats to operational
technology and Internet of Things
what steps has Tesla taking to protect
the company itself and its products from
these threats also as a suggestion
because I know you like suggestions for
the navigation do you think we could do
something on the UI that adds in when
you're about to take the off-ramp to
show a picture of that exit kind of like
other map systems do and then also oh
man this is a lot of questions one of my
friends wanted to get a shock up from
you if that's possible
okay
um
well we are constantly improving the
navigation system
um
and uh uh being robust to hacking is
incredibly important in fact we
um
conduct a lot of sort of uh third-party
hacking contests to try to get the best
hackers in the world to break into our
cars
and actually no one has yet actually
broken it's a a Tesla in a way that
would allow you to really control the
car in a significant way but they have
gotten to where they can like conquer
the horn and mess with the infotainment
system and I'd like to thank them for
their efforts
so we take information security uh
extremely seriously
for navigation
um yeah there's definitely things we can
improve there but really uh down the
road navigation uh visuals are not going
to matter very much because the car is
going to take you wherever you want to
go
um
yeah as for pictures I I I have to I
have to decline unfortunately because
otherwise if I say I I hate being I
actually hate being rude to people so if
I say yes to one person then it's it's
like selfies for a zillion uh you know
it gets kind of gets kind of crazy so
um but thanks for asking maybe we'll
take one or two more questions actually
so
uh
sure
I don't know
sorry hello I I had a question on the
efficiency I don't know if you've been
paying attention to app Tara and I was
curious if you thought that was a space
that you could see Tesla getting into as
far as not just an efficient
manufacturing process but also the
actual car itself and range
I or just buy I'm not I'm not super
familiar with with them but
we have a lot of fish we have a lot of
products to to get done
um it's not like this is it's it's never
a shortage of ideas frankly
I I find ideas to be somewhat trivial
but the execution of the idea is
extremely difficult and as I said like
prototypes are easy production is hard
production and cash flow positive is
excruciating pain that you could like at
a level you cannot believe
so it's it's not product ideas they're
irrelevant tough right so that's what I
think of them
it's sort of like the idea of going to
the Moon that's not who could that's
that's irrelevant getting to the Moon is
the hard part
so okay so maybe one last question yeah
Elon uh John Lopez from Orlando here
I've got two things for you real quick
uh the first one is with Rideshare being
a growing thing especially with Tesla
owners are we going to get a guest mode
option available for that uh the second
thing is is uh as an exploit owner I
would really love to get track mode
yeah as a what's right X plaid
well plaid has track mode the model X
plaid does that though oh oh Model X
um yeah we can probably add that sure
um yeah no problem
um
so ride share is
a bunch of these things will will really
not be relevant in a self-driving World
um you can
um
some in the car and take you somewhere
and if you want to add someone to that
that ride you can if you want to
um but overwhelmingly it is about
achieving uh self-driving full
self-driving and um
you know I think we're really getting to
to the final stages of full self-driving
where
um I mean I drove for several days
around awesome just dropping pins in
random locations and I had zero safety
interventions
so it's really and even in city of San
Francisco which is very complex
um I haven't had a safety intervention
in a long time so
um I think it's uh it's really it's
getting to the point where
you know admittedly I have been
optimistic about this in the past
um uh but I think I think this time
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right I won't say it
all right fair enough all right
[Laughter]
laughs
okay I think it'll happen you know
so
all right you want one last question
sure
so first congratulations on your
decision to try advertising we all want
Tesla Apple in market cap
I don't realize people wanted it that
much okay it's good that a lot of people
agree so early this year you cut prices
on everything 15 20 percent more
recently you've been raising prices on
model y Model S model X
and can you just talk about the pricing
strategy I model like going forward and
keep it separate from the decision to
bring out the next-gen vehicles that we
all agree is going to you know blow the
doors off on volume but just on model y
it's a best-selling product in the in
the in the world
can you just talk about strategy pricing
going forward on that
I mean it's pretty pretty
straightforward I mean we see what the
demand is and then we adjust pricing to
meet the demand
um now the the thing is that um what
what is uh
you know what happens with other car
makers is that they're actually
constantly adjusting pricing on cars
it's just not obvious the in the case of
Tesla you can see immediately when
there's a price change that occurs
because uh we don't have any
intermediaries don't have any dealers
there's no there's no manufactured
manufacturers suggested retail price
um
so but the reality is actually at car
dealers the prices are changing
radically
um I mean last year there were there
were significant premiums above MSRP at
sort of the conventional car dealer you
know like so you'd pay above MSRP last
year and then uh this year I think
things are below MSRP or close to it
um and then the the manufacturers will
then also offer incentives so what's
actually happening is our our very big
uh price shifts
um
by other car makers they're just not uh
obvious
um whereas with Tesla it's obvious
um so and this is this is necessary
because demand fluctuates a lot so
something's got to be done to achieve a
supply demand a clearing point for for
volume
um
so just people are reacting to something
that's obvious as opposed to saying oh
yes every car company does this all the
time
uh Tesla is no exception that's the
actual reality
so
um all right
last question
I'll be really quick okay so I will say
I have been driving FSD my wife drives
FSD there's a a term called the wife
test my wife will only drive our kids on
FSD it's okay
that's that's that that is a great I
mean these sort of significant other
tests is a very uh a good test uh
because there was a while there there
was like you know friends or significant
others would be like please don't put it
on
it's too scary
um but then I guess it's getting to the
point where I mean uh it's it's gonna be
just smooth the silk so in fact you'll
be able to visually tell perhaps even
now you can visually tell if the car is
being driven on FSD or manually because
if it's being driven on FSD it's it's
smooth smooth and precise and if you
look at actual if you actually closely
observed cars going down the highway the
people are constantly moving in their
Lanes so the cars are like doing this
all the time when they're manually
driven if it's if it's actually on FSD
it's it's dead center in the lane
um and and uh it it will actually get to
the point where it is not merely and
maybe is at that point uh not merely uh
safer than a person but actually uh way
smoother uh than manual driving
um
I I just I really I can't say enough
about the profundity of full
self-driving it is it is just one of the
the biggest changes in history that will
occur it's it's not some
feature it's it's like a profound
it's really as profound as
electrification
um and um
and and and and that we have already
have millions of cars in the road that
will literally achieve this with a
software update
I mean that's like head explosion Emoji
you know
um
and um
I think probably a lot of people in this
room realize it but the rest most the
rest of the world doesn't
um yeah so
[Applause]
uh giving how incredible FSD is and how
much you know a marriage you're giving
to potential future margins of the car
um as well as how much an impact on
society and given that they didn't even
want you to say if it's going to happen
this year just you know not to jinx it
sure would it be possible to have just
force of some type of public-facing
investor-facing kind of timeline so that
way you know we you mentioned V12 is
coming and that's you know AI front end
can we could we just see kind of a
timeline on this is the version we're at
these are the things we're working on
and this is when we're you know ETA so
we can kind of see that in real time
instead of uh maybe Elon time
no so the the thing that's been
um
yeah you know um
really difficult with uh full self
driving is that uh
it's it's it very often seems like it's
about to to happen until you realize
that you're actually at a local maximum
and that you need to re-architect
elements of the software
uh to get out of the local maximum to to
then a higher local maximum so it's been
a sort of series of logarithmic curves
um and and that's why it's been like uh
it seemed like oh if you just
extrapolate this on a straight line it
gets the self-driving except that it
it's not a straight line it's a
logarithmic curve and it's sort of and
you start hitting these like local
maximums where you'll sort of asymptote
to a certain capability and then have to
re-architect things so
now I I think we're we're finally at
um a high enough local maximum but will
be this year where to to the point where
it is I think probably safer than than a
person meaning the probability of injury
on average uh will be better than a
person even if the if someone pays no
attention uh to to the car it is worth
saying that that right now
um for human supervised uh Tesla full
self-driving it is dramatically safer
than manual driving
it's like I think like
four times safer maybe more uh so it is
already a massive safety Improvement to
have human supervised uh FSD right now
um and I think we will get to the point
um
where we're always going to be in some
amount of local maximum but I think that
we'll be in a local maximum that exceeds
uh human uh human level safety this year
um
yeah but I guess we'll see so
um anyway I want to thank you all for
for coming and um
so
uh just want to say like you know your
your support is uh super appreciated
um and um you know the as I say A friend
in need is a friend indeed and uh
supporting Tesla when the chips are down
um that that those are the real friends
and and you're them so thank you
all right
okay
[Applause]
[Music]